this is me dumpster diving to find food
for tomorrow's dinner and this is my
face after finding some unexpired steak
in the trash
filet mignon why am I doing this because
we in America have a crisis we throw out
way too much perfectly good food this is
like a pristine cookie 40% of all food
in the u.s. post waste that's 400 pounds
of wasted food per American per year and
this is fully edible food we're talking
about Wow
in developing countries most food waste
happens either on the farm or before the
food even links to the supermarket in
the u.s. it's a different story not only
do supermarkets and restaurants waste a
ton of food but consumers like you and
me waste a lot more we're actually the
single biggest source of that waste hi
my name is yard but I'm also part of the
problem I buy a lot of groceries and
sometimes I just don't eat them all in
time you know life just kind of gets in
the way but here's what's really messed
up while we waste all of this food one
in eight Americans is going hungry
that's over 441 million people so all
this got me thinking why do we waste so
much perfectly good food how can we
rescue it for those of us who don't have
much to eat and what can you and I do to
cut back on waste in our own homes to
fully grasp just how much food we
actually waste hi Janet this is Yara I
tracked down a group of expert dumpster
divers I see them they're right there
who live off what they find in the
garbage wait oh my god I think we found
them so I joined them to go rummaging
through New York City's trash they call
themselves
Cragen's your lifestyle philosophy of
Prague anism is completely opposed to
what they call this wasteful destructive
violent
economic system that supposes that we
have infinite resources when the
opposite is clearly true that's Janet
she's one of their organizers the main
feature of freeganism is to encourage
people to buy as little as possible and
instead rely on salvaging scavenging and
foraging through the trash to find what
you need while cutting down on waste
which is what we did
dumpster diving is generally not against
the law unless the dumpsters on private
property
we've found a the amount of perfectly
edible food we found was unbelievable
especially baked goods this is my
favorite health loaf bagel shops Janet
oh my god you struck a bull right it's
not a gold mine it's a typical night
phase whoa this is a scone and purveyors
of expensive cookies bread doesn't go
bad on the same day that it's baked but
places that baked goods throw them all
out because people don't want
yesterday's bread everywhere we looked
oh my god it's kale this was a great
salad there were mountains of food upon
mountains of food a box full of
chocolate all their best before November
20 20 and even unopened toiletries oh
the paper never expired I am blown away
by how much food we just recovered but
nothing prepared me for what I find
right outside a local grocery store
across the street is our supermarket
there was cheese onions kale kale
lettuce watermelon and the stinking
strawberries you saw earlier but was it
all safe to eat I mean most of it was
but that's not to say dumpster diving
doesn't carry any risks you can get sick
from bad food or hurt yourself if you're
not careful
certain foods like eggs dairy and meat
were riskier to eat especially if they
haven't been refrigerated I'm thinking
of actually maybe eating the sushi I'm
having doubts about eating this sushi
but a lot of what we did was pretty
controlled you dropped by businesses
that freegans had scouted out before
shortly after fresh food was thrown out
in batches we made sure things weren't
contaminated rotten or a half-eaten we
weren't gloves if we had to and took
care of the food we recovered you can
freeze it we just used common sense so
I've never gotten sick just have to be
very practical take the food home look
at it under good light smell it taste a
little bit feel it but which shocked me
the most about our supermarket
discoveries was the amount of completely
unexpired packaged food we found is
anybody fired it's not expired
wait it's not even expired so things
don't only get thrown out because
they're expired they get thrown out
because of the ridiculous rate at which
we have to keep stacking our shelves
altogether the supermarkets are
responsible for over 10 percent of all
food that goes to waste in the US and
Janet's right overstocking store shelves
has a lot to do with it
supermarkets think projecting an image
of abundance helps increase sales and
large case sizes for produce means some
stores are forced to order more than
they can actually sell stores also pull
products off the shelves earlier than
their sell-by dates worried that
customers won't buy them and sometimes
they just dump produce that isn't pretty
enough
compare this to France which in 2016
made it illegal for supermarkets to
throw away food they have the sole
meaning they have to donate it to
charities they couldn't give this to
someone who like doesn't have something
to eat well they could if they lived in
a system where compassion was the
feature of our economy our economy is
not based on compassion it's based on
profit there are people who are
malnourished and there is perfectly good
kale right on the curb it doesn't make
sense to
say that we are a caring society and
we're doing that dumpster diving was
more shocking than I thought it would be
it wasn't that I was finding rotten meat
and moldy vegetables I was finding
perfectly good unexpired food that
supermarkets bakeries cafes and
restaurants were throwing away in
massive quantities at a time when many
can't afford to feed themselves Janet
had invited us over to cook a meal with
all the food we recovered I'm excited
for you to visit but before we did that
there was something else I wanted to
know is there a way to save this food
from making it to the trash in the first
place and instead feed it to those who
don't have enough to eat heading over to
a place called rescue molecular cuisine
these folks pick up food from a bunch of
different places around the city that is
an even that's gonna be thrown out they
reclaim it and then distribute it to
homeless folks and Robert Lee Robert
runs the full operation on a wave and
smile which is also known as RLC so we
grabbed one of their signature carts
Robert I want to carry that to join
forces with another RLC staffer
margarita set out to stop food from
getting anywhere near a dumpster push it
down together okay so first we went to a
start-up can we see what's in it
all that who's would've been thrown out
if it wasn't for us and then we went to
school we're picking up food that was
packed by first graders get all this
food we had and then we dropped
everything up at a homeless shelter
empty
what's cool about RLC is that anyone can
sign up online to rescue food whenever
they have free time and I say hi for the
camera you created change here's the
thing with rescuing food pickups and
drop-offs have to be really fast because
bacteria multiplies rapidly at certain
temperatures any potentially has a food
can't be left out in a pepper today zone
is 40 degrees to 140 degrees for more
than two hours every food business every
cafeteria like we were just in can be
donating the excess sweet incense right
away now it's true a lot of businesses
won't donate food because they're afraid
of getting sued if someone gets sick but
that fear is sort of misplaced there are
actually laws in the u.s. that fully
protect businesses that donate food to
the needy so long as the food is donated
in good faith and there's no public
record of anyone ever being sued for
donating food
and there's a personal story here yeah
definitely my parents were immigrants
here and they struggled my brother and I
remember times when we would not really
know when it was coming from it's
heartbreaking fear your parents like
skip meals he would skip meals just
watch us eat basically and but we
weren't done rescuing food yet there was
one final pickup spot we had to check
out where are we going now we're going
to the Stephen Colbert studio to pick up
their excess - have you met Stephen
Colbert before I have not asked you like
he would be at your home from there we
set out to take it all to one final
drop-off location if you take just one
third of the food that's being wasted
right now brought up to the people who
are food insecure
we got eliminate hunger like we
literally produce enough food especially
everyone we just need to get it to the
right people so far RLC has rescued over
two million pounds of food enough for
1.7 million meals who are the actual
recipients of this food I wanted to meet
them Margherita guided us to a shelter
for men run by the Community Church of
New York yes yes all this time I've been
holding the camera it's strengthened to
my arms that's where we met Bruce Yarra
hi I'm Bruce he's a volunteer with the
shelter so we unloaded the food we
brought for them and this is from
Stephen Colbert's studio oh okay spinach
is our friend stacked bread in a
refrigerator I know that will be
breathlessly entertaining for your
viewers you come here we give you food
we give you an opportunity to clean
yourself up literally you can watch some
TV you can get some sleep people
eventually start to trickle in but no
one was willing to talk to us unless we
agreed to blur their faces I seen cases
of people
who acts for a plate of food or
something to eat
when I stole but a restaurant was
closing and the manager would tell them
to go after yourself or get out of here
we don't have anything for you and then
you'll watch them come out through the
back door knowing just garbage don't
bags and bags of food away this is what
businesses are doing in New York City
they are wasting tons and tons of food I
have two jobs and working two jobs still
doesn't add up to the amount to survive
idiot how would I be able to be
groceries how many feed myself
we safely thrown out by supermarket sir
when we throw it away ourselves so
thoughtlessly we forget that it can
actually change someone's life people
who don't have anything to eat
much less a place to sleep according to
the EPA donating extra food to feed
hungry people is the second most
effective way of reducing food waste but
what's even more effective preventing
the food from becoming waste ourselves
so what can you and I do to cut down on
waste the amount of food that we waste
there that's Margaret Braun a family of
four thought about $1500 a year worth of
food she works for the National
Resources Defense Council which is
basically one of the biggest
environmental advocacy groups out there
so we are the single largest contributor
to food waste here in the are more than
restaurants and grocery stores combined
and why is that well one major reason is
we just don't seem to know when our food
goes back as many as 90% of Americans
have thrown away perfectly good food
because we misinterpret the date labels
on that food a lot of times you find
something with an expired date and then
we just throw it out those dates are not
regulated on almost any product except a
baby formula just to reiterate there are
basically no federal standards on food
expiration dates in the u.s. meaning for
the most part companies decide when food
is best on their own so we recommend the
ATIS using nose and your eyes yeah see
how it looks and that's usually about
that can we do that I guess in your
kitchen let's go through and see like
some of these dates
[Music]
I've never seen honey topa honey never
goes bad ever like thousands of years
[Music]
one that I think is really nice on ocean
is yogurt if your yogurt is kept in your
refrigerator you could be well past your
expiration date and still be fine with
milk I just smell it if it smells a
little off you can use it to make
pancakes it's kind of like butter mother
eggs will stay good much longer than
your expiration date and there's a very
easy way can we do that yeah like if
it's at the bottom that means the
perfectly safe yeah absolutely
what freezer is my biggest food base
avoidance tool suite actually keep
almost all of our bread in the freezer
yeah my grandma also puts bread in the
freezer yeah if you're okay with toast
then you're all set
if I couldn't eat that right away I
would wash them I'd probably take the
tops off and I just think a couple of
things that you can make with like
whatever leftovers you have so these I
used to make quiches with like older
eggs whatever vegetables I have those
pictures what's gonna look pretty
obvious you know who does not care about
that yep five yes I guess dogs aren't
lactose intolerant it's good and the
most important tip of all I would smell
it yes and I would look at it and see if
there's anything growing on it and then
I would probably taste one bean and then
I'd say it's pretty good all right back
to the freegans we all got together at
Janet's house to cook up all the food we
recovered the night before
good to see you
Nathan I excuse everything we're cooking
with tonight right well I'm ready to
help you as we drink smoothies made with
the fruit we found and froze the night
before and ate a fully vegan meal made
with ingredients straight from the trash
it was hard not to think about how this
perfectly good perfectly edible food
almost ended up in a landfill now I'm
not trying to say everybody should just
go and live off what they find in the
garbage but I do think we can all be a
little more mindful about what we buy
and what we throw away these potatoes
are old but they're still good I am
freezing this bread not just in our
homes but in our restaurants businesses
and supermarkets because rescuing
perfectly good food from ever making it
to the trash won't just reduce waste it
could also help feed our fellow humans
hey guys thanks for watching okay to put
notes if you ever hear about anyone
who's afraid to donate food in the US
make sure to tell them about the Good
Samaritan food donation Act which
protects food donations to those in need
also we never got to discussing the
environmental impact of food waste in
this piece or generally food waste
around the world let us know if you'd
like us to cover those topics in another
video as always like comment share
subscribe all the things if you want
more videos like this